[Music]
like Hillary Clinton former Secretary of
State John Kerry apparently enjoys the
immunity from prosecution that being a
powerful leftist brings you today
the Boston Globe revealed recently that
just as President Trump was withdrawing
the United States from the Iran deal
Kerry was working hard to sabotage the
president's foreign policy regarding the
Islamic Republic of Iran Kerry
reportedly sat down at the United
Nations with foreign minister Javad
Zarif to discuss ways of preserving the
pact limiting Iran's nuclear weapons
program this was not apparently a
one-off meeting between Kerry and the
foreign minister of the regime that
orders its citizens to chant death to
America in mosques every Friday the
globe continued it was the second time
in about two months that the two had met
to strategize over salvaging a deal they
spent years negotiating during the Obama
administration according to a person
briefed on the meetings further The
Globe reported that Kerry is not limited
his shadow diplomacy to javad zarif
Kerry also met last month with German
President Frank Volta Stein Maya and
he's been on the phone with top European
Union official federica mogherini Kerry
has also met with French president
Emmanuel macron in both Paris and New
York
conversing over the details of sanctions
and regional nuclear threats in both
French and English Kerry's spokesperson
confirms the meetings but danced around
admitting his behavior why because John
Kerry must know that he's put himself in
violation of a never prosecuted federal
law that only seems to be mentioned when
a conservative is involved for example
former acting Attorney General Sally
Yates said that Michael Flynn should be
prosecuted under this law the Logan Act
the Logan Act forbids unauthorized
people from engaging in negotiations
with foreign governments that are
involved in disputes with the United
States the Logan acts in tension is to
prevent those unauthorized negotiations
from undermining the position of the US
government now isn't that exactly what
Kerry did shouldn't he be arrested and
prosecuted he won't be of course Kerry
deep state peers think he's right and
hoping for his success they couldn't
care less about the Logan act just like
they couldn't care less about the
security of classified State Department
documents when they showed up on Anthony
Weiner's flat top next to his naughty
selfies Carrie's friends who were still
employed in the US government won't be
roused to care about the Logan act
unless one of their own is back in the
White House and lets say former
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo by that
time goes around the world drumming up
support for the trumpian foreign policy
that this neo Obama in the Oval Office
is busy dismantling now of course
Pompeyo is unlikely to do that because
he unlike Kerry and others on the Left
actually respects the law but were he or
some other member of the Trump
administration to do what Kerry is doing
now the media outcry would be immediate
and insistent calling for the arrest and
prosecution of the perpetrator and that
arrest would likely soon follow
the law in the United States is for the
little people and for conservatives
popular culture is obsessed these days
with white privilege that extends even
to shampoo bottles and hotels but the
most heinous example of privilege in
today's society is one that nobody talks
about leftist privilege if you're a
leftist and you want to start a
not-for-profit organization no problem
only conservative organizations get
buried in mountains of red tape and
hobbled by unexplained delays from the
IRS if you're a leftist and you start a
news website you'll have loads of
readers referred to your site from
Facebook Twitter and all the rest only
conservative sites are being
systematically blocked its leftist
privilege if you're a leftist president
you can oversee a corrupt and lawless
administration for eight years and then
brag about how your presidency was
scandal free you won't hear a murmur of
dissent from an establishment media that
worked hard throughout those years to
make sure that as few people as possible
knew about your real scandals and if
you're John Kerry you can traverse the
globe doing everything you can to
undermine the foreign policy of the
United States government secure in the
confidence that you will not face any
consequences at all you're John Kerry
you're a made guy in the leftist
political elite you could shoot somebody
in the middle of Fifth Avenue and awaken
the next morning to adoring headlines in
the New York
times I'm Robert Spencer a showman
fellow for the David Horowitz freedom
Center and director of jihad watch this
video has been brought to you by the
Center for security policy